[Music]
[Applause]
here we are having a blast doing and
getting a chance to interview someone
like Clint Dempsey you've done an
unbelievable job by the way awesome job
as a studio analyst for Fox during the
World Cup saw him yesterday after the
game did a terrific job by the way Clint
where are you right now
we're at the fox set here in uh Doha
Qatar
oh that looks awesome man really
appreciate you coming on the show it's
Ross Tucker I got the call late last
night that Dan was under the weather so
I'm filling for him former NFL offensive
lineman although as I mentioned earlier
I was on the why I'm missing under eight
under 10 and under 12 a team for soccer
to clinch just so you know not the B
team I made a team all six years all
right that's what I'm talking about you
know what I've always wanted to ask you
by the way you by the way you might be
one of my favorite soccer players to
ever watch just like the attitude you
played with the aggression
um you got I could tell you got some uh
some football player in you what always
blew me away about you Clint is that
you're from Texas like I guess knowing
what I know I played for the Cowboys
like I'm amazed that you came from Texas
because I just don't Picture People even
being allowed to play soccer in Texas
how did that happen yeah
yeah I mean I grew up in a small town
Nacogdoches one of the oldest town
oldest town in Texas and uh was playing
everything growing up and I just kind of
gravitated towards that sport we had a
large Hispanic uh population uh in our
community and was able to play the game
with them and then took my game to
Dallas to play at the club level but
yeah all through High School people are
talking trash why are you playing this
sport why are you doing that and I guess
it ended up working out I ended up being
able to represent my country in the
world cup three World Cups was able to
be a captain one of those World Cups and
uh yeah I was able to be a kid for a
little bit longer by playing the game
that I loved
well it definitely worked out for you
thoroughly enjoyed watching you in all
those World Cups and thoroughly enjoyed
watching yesterday I live uh Clint I
live five minutes from Hershey her she's
right down the street so obviously what
Christian has been able to do is very
exciting for all of us let's just start
though with the game itself I just kind
of want your overall breakdown of the
game yesterday against Iran
okay yeah I mean going into the third
game uh we've got we got two draws
the first game you feel like almost it's
a draw but it felt like a loss we're
winning when nothing we've conceded the
penalty in the 83rd minutes of Wales the
second game we got to draw against
um England being the underdog we fought
hard and and we showed
um a lot of grit and we had a lot of the
better chances we could have won that
game that draw ended up feeling like a
win but the problem you have going into
that last game is we only had two shots
on goal and where the goal is going to
come from and talking about people who
are going to step up Christian uh
pulisic was one of the guys that um
when's he gonna have his moment even
though he did get the assist in the
first game was he going to be able to to
get his goal and what a goal he got uh
they got us uh the the first goal got us
the the win but first half the whole
tournament I think we played good in
every single first half but
two of the the the second half so I
didn't think we played played well in
the whales game I didn't think we played
well we sat back we absorbed pressure we
conceded the penalty got the draw and
the last game I just felt like the
second half we just sat back absorbed
pressure and made it stressful for all
the American fans uh watching at home I
just would like to see us be a little
bit more have a little bit more depth in
our team it just looks like when
Christian went out when Western McKinney
goes out he seems to be having an injury
that only allows him to play 60s 65 70
minutes and once some players start to
come out of that starting 11 you start
to see a drop in our team and also I
think we're still looking for that
number nine I thought Sergeant did play
well in the last game and with this Hold
Up play and creating chances so it'd be
interesting to see what we end up doing
uh in in the The Knockout stadiums
versus Netherlands well I appreciate you
saying that because as a guy that you
know as a football player the second
half I was very frustrated because the
first half we were utterly dominant so
many chances on goal even that second
goal by way uh yeah I thought was
borderline on the offsides you'd have to
tell me if that was legit or not but
then the second half it was like we were
just trying to hold on I mean we were
clearly the better team I didn't really
understand why it seemed like they took
the we barely even controlled the ball
at all in the second half
yeah I just think we lost a little bit
of the Rhythm with Christian not being
in there he's he's more of a threat and
has a better uh Hold Up play and being
able to take the game to the opponent
Weston McKinney going out
um because of you know the the
monitoring his injury that he's come
back into the game with and I thought we
made too many defensive changes in the
uh the 80th minute when he knew that
there was going to be a lot of time
added on and even though we saw the game
out and the subs look like they work in
my opinion it just we absorbed a lot of
pressure we put a lot of people in the
back and I think at times people didn't
know who needed
where and it was just kind of like
certain players came on the pitch they
weren't able to link passes it almost
looked like they were a little bit out
of their debt but at the end of the day
a lot of these guys it's their first
World Cup the only player with World Cup
experience is DeAndre Yedlin so in in
terms of what this group has been able
to do get out of the group and now have
the opportunity to do something special
against Netherlands hopefully we can get
as many people back on the pitch healthy
and uh look forward to uh making history
let's talk about the ballistic goal
Clint because you mentioned it
um obviously it was awesome that he you
could see him ahead of time see that
there might be that opportunity on the
cross and get the the explosiveness to
get past the defender uh your thoughts
on his goal and then in particular the
injury he suffered because we've been
talking a lot I mean it was very clear
to me that he took a knee to the nuts
right when he scored the goal has that
ever happened to you is that a common
thing in soccer
I mean there's all kinds of things that
happen you know I broke my nose broke my
jaw you know broke both my wrists I mean
you're gonna you're gonna put your body
on the lawn uh good things will happen
but sometimes bad things happen but the
thing that impressed me most about the
goal is the 12 13 passes that led to it
that would have been Spain everybody
would have been showing all the passes
in the build up instead of just the
Highlight so that was good to see how
we're changing the way that that soccer
is perceived uh in other countries and
at home but yeah great ball from Western
McKinney I think our Midfield has been
unbelievable this whole tournament and
uh good ball to sergino Des who gets the
ball across uh the goal the gold mouth
and then Christian
having the hunger smelling it out
putting his body on the line and really
giving us that moment his moment that
you know adding to his legacy of what
he's been able uh to do in this game uh
for our country so hopefully he'll get
back I'm hearing it's a pelvic contusion
and um you know he was all happy Spirits
uh it showed some videos of him after
the game so hopefully they're able to to
manage that and he can get back on the
pitch
what about the the goal by way uh on the
offsides I guess first of all did you
agree with the offsides call and then
just a more general question do you
think that that should be the rule that
like if any part of your body is in
front because I mean he seemed like he
was pretty even man
yeah I mean I I kind of agree with you I
made that point to Alexi and he's like
where do you draw the line you're either
pregnant or you're not and I'm like well
if anybody knows about being pregnant
it's me my family because we've had dang
six kids but for me I feel like if half
of your body is in line with with the
other player that like in baseball I
feel like the Ty should go to the runner
right you want to see more goals you
want to see more exciting things that
happen on the pitch and for me I agree
with you I would like for that to be the
case but it isn't if any part of your
body is ahead of the other person like
if you're running a race well then it's
going to be an all-size call they got it
to the with the technology now that they
can show that line but I'm with you I'd
like to see if it's close Let It Go with
the attacking team
love it that makes me feel better I'm
that I feel better about that now all
right let's get into the Netherlands now
what do we need to know I've seen some
of the odds on DraftKings and other
places that it seems like we're a pretty
heavy Underdog do you agree with that
and why
yeah I mean I think so in terms of the
World Cup experience that we have but I
think the speed this team feeds off
being the underdog because you look how
they played against England they they
were the underdog in that match but I
think they had the better chances to be
honest with you and it looked like we
could have won that game
um things to watch out for with this uh
Netherlands side obviously Virgo Van
Dyke in the back he's going to be tough
to break down
um he's just a strong presence there in
the Midfield you got Dion that plays at
Barcelona but I think our Midfield will
be able to nullify that but also you got
to watch out for gakpo and the pie the
pie now is gonna back into the team
being more fit
um he's contributed probably what 42
goals and and 83 games that he's played
for his coach he's averaging a goal a
game he had a part to play in both of
the goals they scored in their last game
and then gakpo he's the player that
scored in every single game of the group
stage so we're gonna have to figure out
a way to calm him down and calm him down
and not let him stay on the fire that um
the hot streak that he's on so be aware
of those guys but I think hey we got a
good chance as any against this team and
long as we have our players fit I like
our Fighting Chance
make sure you check out Clint daily on
Fox and fs1's FIFA World Cup Tournament
coverage leading all the way up to the
gigantic round of 16 match for the U.S
man this Saturday morning versus the
Netherlands live coverage starts on Fox
at 9 00 a.m Eastern from Qatar with
kickoff at 10 A.M Eastern can't wait
Clint thank you so much for the time man
really appreciate it hey appreciate you
bro take care